[Music]  all right tomorrow night you me what we  call us if there's any trouble okay call  don't cause any trouble  I bet be us boys over at your place all  the time  that's what babysitter's do seriously  have you ever been a week after she's  fallen asleep  I love her  [Music]  babysitter is trying to kill me are the  attackers the dice chairs in your past  all righty babes let's head upstairs and  get the blood of the enemy  this would go viral I mean nobody's done  human sacrifice people have always done  human sacrifice yeah but like not in  America with hot people Hey  [Music]  see when you make a deal with the devil  why is he shirtless that's your first  question  [Music]  we're gonna ditch the girl in the boom  you guys suck  [Music]  you crazy [ __ ]  [Music]  you